i want to speak a little bit here about
one of the greatest guitar players that
ever lived
when eddie van halen came on the scene i
had never heard guitar playing like that
you knew something superior was
happening
i remember going to see um when sammy uh
first joined up
sammy and eddie were wearing like these
pantalones
like uh like these like blousy kind of
pants
with the cut off shirts and the bandanas
tied around their necks
and they could pull off those outfits
and i was like god
it's exactly what i want to look like
it's the exactly kind of talent i want
and it's exactly what i want to be doing
in life i want to be on stage
rocking this [__] music and playing
metal music and
then when eddie started playing and
you're watching you couldn't take your
eyes off them
that guitar is like it's part of his
body
and his hands are moving and i'm sitting
there going
jesus christ this is this is it you know
the disturbing thing was eddie always
um had a cigarette lit on stage he did
that move where you take the cigarette
and you put it in the necky guitar he
starts eruption he's got the cigarette
hanging out of his mouth
and the smoke is going in his eyes and
it's blowing up in his face and he's
still playing
then while he's holding the guitar with
his left hand playing he takes the right
hand he takes a couple of drags on the
cigarette sticks it back into the neck
of the guitar
and i'm like this [__] can do it
i'm blowing smoke rings
and blowing smoke rings and i'm like he
is so relaxed with that guitar it is so
a part of his life
it is so a part of him and you know what
kills me this is the thing i'm hung up
on
thousands and thousands of hours of
guitar playing
all of that talent all of that expertise
is gone now it's like
okay we have recordings of it but it's
gone
and it drives me crazy where does all
that talent go where does that go
and will we ever see another one like
him i don't think so i mean the guy was
so innovative
in fact i asked steve now wiki steve
you're a guitar player steve loves eddie
van halen he owns a bunch of those uh
eddie van halen guitars
give me a little bit of um background on
what you know about eddie van halen
guitars and some of his great techniques
so the way i mean eddie changed the way
that people
physically play guitar like everybody
knows the two hands on the neck
uh tapping thing which sounds like this
and all that i mean he pioneered um this
piece of uh technology it's called the
floyd rose tremolo with the whammy bar i
mean he really pioneered this which
developed all these sounds of like
eddie said in some interview that
he was so poor he didn't have money for
these
you know wawa pedals and effects pedals
so he had to build a guitar and rely on
his fingers and playing to get all of
these effects that he eventually got out
of the guitar is that right
right and he bought the cheapest guitar
you know this is a
replica i built of his frankenstein
frankenstein red guitar
he said i named it frankenstein because
of all the different parts i found it
was like putting together a body uh
you know a dead body he took this from
that and that from this and
and he created frankenstein the guitar
these are actually ones that i built i
wanted to go through
the same process that eddie made like i
did the paint job on it i bought the
61071 neck plate and the reflectors on
the back of it and all that uh
show us why eddie van halen is uh
notches above other guitar players
so i'll show you this this is one of the
coolest things where he makes his guitar
sound like a violin basically where he's
rolling up the volume knob and then he's
got this echo effect on it so it comes
out like this
[Music]
[Applause]
so
yeah that is just an amazing sound isn't
it
yeah and i mean he did things with
harmonics or i don't know if you know
harmonics but it's when you tap the
string lightly
so he would do this thing called pinch
harmonics
but he would also do tap harmonics which
he came up with where you're tapping on
it like
[Applause]
[Music]
by the way i should mention that deep
tracks channel 27 is now an eddie van
halen tribute channel i'm i'm just doing
a little tiny tribute but this is going
to go on
24 hours a day eddie van halen also did
the beat it
the riff and beat it yeah which is so
great
[Music]
[Applause]
and then when sammy hagar came in the
band this is what's remarkable
he went from david lee roth to sammy
hagar and then had bigger hits with
sammy hagar
which is rarely done in rock i remember
i thought the band was over
it was over right i tried to get in
touch with sammy yesterday
sammy uh didn't want to come on the air
today but he
said that i understand yeah he says he's
not up to talking in person but he did
send me this note so i'll share it with
you
i would love you to share that eddie and
i
had been texting and it's been a love
fest since we started communicating
earlier this year
we both agreed not to tell anyone
because of all the rumors it would stir
up about a reunion etc and we both knew
that wasn't going to happen but he also
didn't want anyone to know about his
health
he stopped responding to me a month ago
and i figured it wasn't good
i reached out one more time last week
and when he didn't respond i figured it
was a matter of time
but it came way too soon and that is
signed by
sami hagar himself so that's what
sammy's thinking about
so these guys it's rather shocking these
guys uh kept it quiet but they were
texting one another
and uh you know i never you know even
when sammy was on the show the last time
and he was here with
michael anthony those guys you know they
weren't bad-mouthing
eddie van halen they were just doing
their own thing but i'm sure
that this is an emotional day for david
lee roth and for
for definitely sammy of course and
michael anthony's
alex and alex you feel really bad for
alex because they never left each other
they were
always together from childhood till now
those two brothers were together by the
way
i thought as a capper i would show you
this
one of my most uh prized possessions
robin yes a guitar that mr
edward van halen gave me and as you can
see
this guitar i got a piece of plastic
over the neck
but this guitar is called wolfgang named
after his son
uh-huh no wiki eat your heart out um you
didn't bill that
eddie just gave that to you and on it
eddie wrote howard
i don't care what people say about you
really in parentheses or me all the best
eddie van halen looks like he put the
date
looks like 98 something like that there
you go
i hope that was a fitting tribute for
the one and only
eddie van halen
you